all right well we have another possible
crime that donald trump or people around
him may have committed this one relates
to
what i call a revenge audit by the irs
this is um a couple things to understand
about this and one of course is that
what we have right now is something
circumstantial and suspicious that is
increasingly being
focused on trump and people around him
we don't yet know the full story but
this is uh salon has um
reported on
the uh reality
that both james comey and andrew mccabe
were subjected to
irs audits now these audits are very
rare and so to see two high-ranking fbi
officials
both uh targeted by audits that have a
one in thirty thousand per year
prevalence
it starts to raise some red flags former
fbi director james comey and his top
deputy andrew mccabe faced rare
intensive irs audits after investigating
former president donald trump according
to the new york times
comey whom trump fired in 2017
uh ann mccabe who was similarly as to
comey fired after investigating trump
were selected for quote random audits
known as autopsy without the benefit of
death these are like the most invasive
audits out of about 153
million individual tax returns from 2017
only 5 000 people were selected for this
type of invasive audit each year now
we'll get to the math okay but the point
is these are extremely rare and for the
former fdi fbi director and the former
fbi deputy director to both be targeted
by these audits
it starts to be a little strange
comey mccabe and their spouses defied
the odds being selected for the audit
after being fired
the two men were selected for an irs
research program that uses compliance
research examinations to try to catch
tax cheats unlike typical audits these
audits force individuals to produce bank
records copies of checks receipts and
letters effectively recreating their
finances for the year in question this
takes months and often costs thousands
in accounting fees in my experience and
i've not been audited but in talking to
accountants about it it's more than
thousands for this this this could be
tens of thousands
um the irs said in letters to both men
your federal income tax return for the
year shown above was selected at random
for a compliance research examination
we must examine randomly selected tax
returns to better understand tax
compliance and improve fairness of the
tax system
the minuscule chance of the two top fbi
officials being selected at random
raised questions about whether trump
appointees in the government or irs
purposely targeted them
lightning strikes and that's unusual and
that's what it's like being picked out
for one of these audits said irs
commissioner former irs commissioner
john koskinen the question is does
lightning then strike again in the same
area does it happen some people may see
that in their lives but most will not
trump spokeswoman has denied even
knowing about these audits okay so let's
do some math and i know the math is not
easy on this so i know that the math
people will tell me whether i'm wrong so
first first things first
if the odds of this audit is one in
thirty thousand or the odds are one in
thirty thousand
if you say what are the odds of two
specific people facing the same audit
you would get one in 900 million
assuming that every person is equally
likely to be audited that doesn't really
reflect the situation
uh in particular because you would
imagine
that a large number of my my guess is
that even if we believe the audits are
random
they're probably not being done for
people below a certain level of income
and that would probably be for two
reasons one that the amount that the irs
even stands to recover from someone who
might have cheated on their taxes if
they made 40 grand is very very low so
that's one thing and number two
the mechanisms that are often used to
avoid taxes or evade remember avoidance
and evasion are two different things
one's legal one is not um are much more
commonly used by people of higher
incomes so
it's it's not even the right number
because it's not the entire population
that is probably even really at risk for
this type of audit it's some subset of
that above a certain income level okay
but the other thing about this is that
there's the missing context of
well it's actually
four people because it's these two guys
and their spouses and i believe they
were in different years so if your risk
of this is one in thirty thousand each
year if we look over like the three year
period where trump could have
theoretically directed this or indicated
someone should do this then it's sort of
like three in thirty thousand it gets
complicated but i think what we have to
understand are a couple things one
this is very rare and two
to see both of the top fbi people
targeted with this
supposedly randomly
during a time when they were adversarial
to the president who appointed people to
the irs we know the president is one of
the most vindictive and childish
probably the most vindictive and
childish president that we've ever had
it is weird and so i'm not ready to say
trump directed this i'm not ready to say
it was even necessarily
uh within trump's purview
but
it's strange enough that it should be
investigated and one of the things we
have to remember also is like imagine
that it was something trump did in
theory this is a federal crime
uh but
trump really exposed how easy it is
to just ignore all of the checks and
balances on people in positions of power
and uh if this was a retaliatory irs
audit whoever directed it aside from
whoever did it
should be investigated should be charged
if that's what that's what happened but
trump flouted all sorts of different
norms and checks and balances and at
least for now there have not really been
any consequences so we learned that the
framers
set up some checks and balances but they
clearly assumed no one would ever
flout them that's flout
uh to the degree that donald trump did
and so how strong are those checks and
balances
if they can be ignored with essentially
no consequences we will continue to get
answers to that
yesterday we talked on the podcast
about how at this early stage i mean
listen it's not even an early stage
we're not even at the 2024 primary
season we're not even beyond the 2022
primaries
there have been some republicans that
are already endorsing donald trump jim
jordan for example
we have also seen some republicans
declare
they will not support donald trump even
if he does run
this is starting to get even weirder
because donald trump has now signaled
that he is running in 2024 in a bizarre
truth social post in which he referred
to himself
as the future president of the united
states seems very clearly to be saying
i'm running let's review this bizarre
post trump writing quote
why would a future president of the
united states want to have
candidate-important conversations with
his white house counsel
if he thought there was even a small
chance that this person essentially
acting as a lawyer for the country
may someday be brought before a partisan
and openly hostile committee in congress
or even a fair and reasonable committee
to reveal the inner secrets of foreign
policy or other important matters so bad
for the usa trump really a legend in his
own mind so what is he talking about i
know you might see this and say that's
like a verbal inkblot that what is that
trump is referring to his former white
house counsel pat sipoloni which i last
week was pronouncing chipoloni people
very politely corrected me and they said
it is actually uh only pronounced
sipoloni no
we all make mistakes so trump here is
saying listen
uh
this was the
lawyer for the country
but that is a fundamental
misunderstanding the white house counsel
is the president's lawyer now in an
ideal world the president's interests
are aligned with the country's interests
in particular when donald trump was
president
the country's interests and trump
interests were completely at odds they
were not in any way aligned and so the
idea that pat sipoloni by representing
president trump is representing the
interests of the country is nonsense now
the other thing is that
he wasn't having the conversation so he
says
as if me as a future president i'm
disincentivized from talking to my
lawyer if i think my lawyer might
someday be dragged before a committee
trump's conversations with sipoloni when
trump was president
were not conversations as a future
president if that was the case you might
be able to make a stronger argument that
they are protected by attorney-client
privilege sipolone can't be forced to
testify we wouldn't even be having this
discussion trump was the president
sipoloni represented him they were
actively engaged in inciting a riot
trying to overturn an election trump
lost all these different things and of
course sipilone's testament testimony
would be eminently reasonable and
relevant and it's supposedly going to be
happening behind closed doors sippiloney
today
scheduled to be speaking to the house
committee whether it happens we will we
will figure that out now
for one moment i thought did trump mean
as a future prisoner rather than as a
future president that's wishful thinking
i don't expect that to happen now a few
hours later just to kind of close the
circle on this insanity trump added some
other strange comments and subsequent
posts also related to the investigations
into him writing quote
both of my phone calls to georgia were
perfect now of course those were the
calls where trump asked for votes i need
11 000 votes give me a break trump going
on and saying i had an absolute right to
make them and in fact the story on the
one call was given a retraction or
apology by the washington post because
they were given terribly false
information about it now that's not true
and when they heard the actual call they
realized their story was wrong
thank you to the washington post i as
does anyone else just look at the
democrats have the absolute right to
challenge the results of an election
this one corrupt rigged and stolen
continuing saying quote i did nothing
wrong in georgia but others did they
cheated in the 2020 presidential
election and those are the ones that
should be investigated and prosecuted
letter to follow and i have not seen the
letter that supposedly follows this is a
desperate
unhinged man
clawing any relevance that he can obtain
and of course it's always the opposite
for six months he said the democrats are
going to try to steal the election
he tried to steal the election for
months he said the democrats are going
to mess with these ballots
dumps of ballots and mail-in ballots and
ultimately it was trump and his
followers and his lawyers going around
the country making bogus claims about
those very mail-in ballots the
allegations are ultimately confessions
with these guys we've got to be ready
for 2022 and we've got to be ready for
2024. will we be ready that's the
question let me know what you think find
me on twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program you can
support us most directly with very few
intermediaries by signing up at
joinpacman.com i would love for you to
do that let's hear from people in the
audience we take calls on the friday
show via discord you can find our
discord at davidpakman.com
discord this is free
everyone's welcome to call in discord is
free calling in is free it's all free
i've got nothing to sell you other than
a good time
let's start today
wow
how about nevin from tennessee nevin
welcome
nevin you're on the air i heard a noise
so i know you're unmuted welcome
hey
uh i was just asking about
can you hear me
yes i can evan okay okay thank you so i
was just asking about
uh do you think it's a good strategy for
democrats to infiltrate like republican
primaries to try and get the least
radical candidate nominated like
the um wyoming one with liz cheney do
you think we should go into that primary
vote in it to get liz cheney nominated
over the other guys
yeah it's a case-by-case question in
very so wyoming being so red
the winner of that primary will almost
certainly be the not be the winner so in
that case i think it makes sense there
are other races where it's much tighter
in terms of whether a democrat or a
republican could win and the efforts
would be better served working on
supporting the democratic candidate and
sometimes you can have a situation where
it's better for the republican nominee
to be crazier because it will help the
democrat right so you have to use your
judgment in the liz cheney example it
makes a lot of sense to me
all right thank you that was all i had
to ask how are things in tennessee okay
uh it's a deep red state so obviously
not great but so not great okay all
right we'll keep on keeping on my friend
all right
thank you okay i appreciate the call
there's nevin from tennessee it's deep
red so it's not going that well you hate
to hear that you really do
let's go uh oh you know who we haven't
heard from for for a while our friend
tamisha in new york city tamisha welcome
thank you how is everything everything's
good
um
um i'm calling because i wanted to just
quickly talk about the absurdity of the
guns talk yeah from right where they say
oh um let's arm doors locked doors and
rooftops but
that whole premise doesn't make any
sense because it would mean you would
have to arm every public place you would
have to lock every public place right
and is that really realistic to have um
armed guards everywhere all the time
wouldn't that be like a
welfare state
well it wouldn't be it's not a welfare
state it'd be more like a police state
police state there you go yeah yeah yeah
it's completely unrealistic and you know
the thing about it is
they never want to just say let's try
dealing with the guns like we've talked
about all this other stuff and we've
said the issues mental illness but then
they won't fund mental health and then
they say the issues doors but then
there's an outdoor shooting and then
they say well the issue is fire escapes
but then there's one at a movie theater
you know i mean
they want to just push around the
responsibility and never deal with the
guns and you're absolutely right it's
like well i guess everybody should wear
body armor at a parade and everyone
should wear a helmet at the movies and
like how far is this going to go before
we say hey you know what let's just try
dealing with the guns
and it's like most most common sense
people are not trying to take away guns
they're just trying to make it so crazy
people don't get them yeah i mean it's
like listen there's some people who want
to get rid of the second amendment i
take a more fatalistic approach which is
like for now we have a second amendment
let's work within it let's require
liability insurance let's make
ammunition really expensive let's limit
the guns that someone under 25 can have
let's have a waiting period let's have a
psych eval let's have more extensive
training all these different things
let's just really make it so that
only the cream of the crop so to speak
can get the guns
well that's where the common sense part
comes in but we're dealing with
people without common sense and that
brings me to the next thing where yeah
i'm coming to this similar conclusion to
you where our electorate is just not
very bright right
it's like i talk to people and they talk
about gas prices inflation and they talk
about um democratic policies and oh um
the left is
too woke and the left is too this too
crazy and radical but then they very
much ignore the radicalness that's on
the right side of course there's so much
craziness that goes on on the right um
and so much authoritarian it's all
ignored because and i like i've even
heard people
that i know that are not republicans
that talk about how they like desantis
like you were saying with yeah with
rogan
i'm like really i and i don't like to
play the race card but i'm like you're a
person of color i really don't
understand he's he and or
how you um support the lgbtq community i
don't understand how you can support
anything he stands for everything he
stands for is against any of that yeah i
think he has a zero rating on lgbt stuff
i mean listen it's unfor it's really
unfortunate to mesha but we're in a
world
where most people are incompetent and i
know oh it's so elitist and it's so
condescending and it's so pompous i mean
listen at this point i've worked with a
bunch of real estate agents they were
mostly all terrible at their jobs other
than two at this point i've had you know
over 20 however many years of driving
how many mechanics have i had they've
mostly been terrible at their jobs and
now i know a good mechanic uh i've had
you know whatever like it's just it's so
common that people are just incompetent
or only minimally competent and we're
kind of trying to dance through this and
you know what
i could be incompetent too i'm not even
saying i'm exempt from this but it's a
reality that we're dealing with here
yeah i agree like i wouldn't say that i
know everything but i do try to be
informed when i form opinions i don't
just form opinions based on what
somebody tells me i try to you know do
my research and form an opinion based on
facts but it's just like some people
just listen to propaganda or news
outlets and they say well that's that's
the way things are because they said it
yes and i'm like but um
like there's so much nuance even with
the vaccinations i hear people say well
you could still get it i was like
there's so much nuance that there's
barrier variants people didn't get it at
first so it was allowed to spread it's
like there's so much nuance to it that
it's not as simple as oh if you get if
you get the vaccine you can still get it
so that means the vaccine doesn't work
that's just a simplified way to think of
it 100
100 percent to misha the kids are okay
yes they both a school 90 um high honors
so i'm very proud of them 90s good
well 97 actually 97. oh my god okay
all right well great to hear from you i
appreciate it
thank you all right there's demesha from
new york city always great to hear from
her uh let's go next to you know i kind
of want to figure out what's going on in
florida a little bit
let's go next to jorge in florida now
jorge are you in florida or florida
hello
jorge
well i guess we're not going to figure
out let's try instead manuel from
florida welcome
hey um
nice to speak with you likewise florida
is doing doing just fine is that right
yeah it feels like i'm walking out into
an oven whenever i leave my house though
so it's pretty hot
well at least the house isn't so hot
yeah no that's true the bills are pretty
high because of that but i bet yeah we
have to take it i'm curious what's like
your what's your like
top electrical bill in the summer
so i have this like 1 500 square foot
house and in the summer it could get to
250 dollars
oh i have to tell you that's not that
bad and you keep you're running the ac
almost 24 7 i assume
oh yeah okay that's actually not that
shocking that's that's all right well
fair i thought you were going to tell me
800 or something
oh wow i didn't know
electricity was that expensive in other
places i i think there are places where
if you run the ac all every day you can
get some crazy bills yeah but good
you're not that's a problem you're not
dealing with at least
yes yeah yes
um but yeah i did wanted to ask you this
question so i was speaking with somebody
uh about
you know this contentious topic of
abortion rights and whatnot yes and you
know the the topic tends to revolve
around
when life begins and stuff
and i've heard people say
that
it's science can't tell us when it
begins i've heard people say
science can't even tell us
when it ends
and i just get kind of concerned and i
wonder is it practical for us to
to make such definitions or should we
look at life and death
like a in in a nuanced way and
like uh yeah well i don't actually think
i don't think the solution
is everybody agrees to look at when life
begins in a nuanced way i think what the
issue is that
even if we got some answer as to when
life begins it still isn't going to
change anyone's mind if they're against
abortion for religious reasons
if imagine that science said hey you
know what
and and by the way
the real issue is when are we talking
about a person not when life begins i
mean no one would deny that a clump of
cells is a form of life
the relevant question is are we talking
about a person and if it's a person does
it get due process does it get
citizenship does it get child support
can you get the child tax credit when
you're pregnant you know all these other
things that that are really about
personhood rather than life but imagine
that science said hey
life begins at nine weeks and six days
into the gestational period
do we then all agree about abortion i
mean it just it in that sense it's a red
herring you know what i mean
yeah 100
and whenever i do talk about this i do
like to frame it in the the personhood
kind of way right because
i mean science is ever changing and and
who knows right like
we may
understand that a nine-week old fetus
has a full conscious right but at the
end of the day we assign personhood
um and we value
like
the choice of the woman in her life and
her safety
in these ways right regardless of
of that but yeah personhood is great but
i just get
i get worried because it kind of makes
pro-choice
sound crazy when people
say things like well we actually never
know
like it's impossible to know and it's
also impossible to know
like when people die like i mean it just
makes things feel relative and i don't
know i kind of
i get lost in that yeah yeah i mean i
think there's some value to the speed
limit analogy which is like listen
sometimes to live in a society
we have to draw lines where there are
gray areas so you probably would have
imagine a road where you go listen a
hundred miles an hour no one's going to
say 100 miles an hour is a reasonable
speed limit here and no one's going to
say that it's 5. we're going to set the
speed limit at 40
and certainly if it's dry and clear you
could probably safely go 55 if it's dark
and icy you're going to have to go
slower but we're this is where we're
kind of drawing the line and when we get
into these
rare circumstances of like partial birth
abortions as they're sometimes called
late-term abortions everybody has a term
that's loaded that they want to apply to
it and then they say well uh it's it's
we're talking about a person at seven
months and someone goes well here's one
way where it would really be six and
here's another way it
from the standpoint of policy sometimes
lines have to be drawn when things are
blurry but this is a different question
then if we got an answer to when life
begins then do we resolve the debate the
answer is obviously no
yeah 100 well thanks a ton for your time
and thank you for the call i appreciate
it all right there's manuel from florida
let's just stick in florida a little bit
because i am curious what's going on
let's go to david in florida david
welcome
david
if this is me
it is you
cool i
love the show i just wanted to have a
question something that was on my brain
a while ago okay um you would ask a lot
of the republican or more trumpian
republican side if they can answer the
simple question of you know who's the
president
now my thought was isn't that a
citizenship question if you can answer
who the president is i'm not saying to
take away
citizenship as the final result but if
they can't answer a simple question you
know what are we doing here that's a
good question i don't know uh let's see
u.s citizenship questions and answers
um
i don't know if who is the current
president is on there it very well may
be
uh name your representative name your
senator seems to be on there i don't see
who is the president let me see oh no
what is the name of the president of the
united states yeah that's true well
listen i don't think it'll come as a
shock to you
that lots of people who got citizenship
by birth
could not actually pass the citizenship
test in the united states i mean we we
used to do like man on the street stuff
where i would ask people who's your
senator or name any senator and tons of
people wouldn't wouldn't get those
answers right so this goes back to the
thing i was talking about with tamisha
about you know probably 80 of people are
sort of like incompetent to some degree
unfortunately i'm going to have to agree
with you on that one yeah but uh i'll
i'll relieve any of the any uh extra
time i have to someone else from florida
okay well i don't have anyone else what
what part of florida are you in
um down in fort lauderdale about an hour
north of miami oh okay yeah that's not a
that's not a bad area i mean listen if i
had to live in florida which i'm to be
totally frank it's not out of the
possibility that i would in the future
spend significant time in florida i
would be in one of two places i would
either be in the miami area or i would
be in pensacola which i know sounds
weird it's like the panhandle you know
but we've got some great friends up
there and you know there's a jew or two
in pensacola it's not just waspi
i of the two i would have to say uh
pensacola would be uh the better choice
you can probably get a little bit more
land uh it's probably a little bit
quieter down in miami i'm looking at
dinner tonight and trying to make a
reservation the reservation said you
have to spend a hundred dollars per
guest so is that right
what restaurant is that
this was uh sugar it's uh just a nice
view of miami with some seafood um
i wanted to do something a little nice
but maybe not two hundred dollars nice
yeah yeah hey have you been to mandolin
aegean bistro
i have not i'm gonna have to look that
one up though that's a hot place if you
can get in there i love it there
i appreciate it thank you okay thanks
for the call appreciate there's david
from florida we're gonna take the
quickest of quick breaks if you're
holding don't go anywhere because i'm
going right back to the phones in a
moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's hear
from a few more people when we take
calls we do so via discord you can find
our discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to ben
from san angelo ben welcome to the show
hello can you hear me i can hear you
fine
okay great
um now i have a question to ask you
about the u.s presidency okay um are you
familiar with the c-span's presidential
historian survey no
okay um well i really like it it was
last updated in 2021
um it asks about
140
different
i guess historians what they thought
about the presidents
and um i guess my question is
do you think that um
using the
survey here
is a good way to um sort of talk to
others about you know presidents and the
really bad presidents versus the really
good ones
um i mean listen i'm looking at it now
and just to give people context
basically the historians rank the
presidents and
lincoln basically is always number one
george washington goes between two and
three fdr goes between three and two
teddy roosevelt is almost always in
fourth when you look at recent
presidents um barack obama
was uh ranked i guess it's like around
10th
trump is ranked fourth to the worst the
the only people ranked worse than trump
per historians are franklin pierce
andrew johnson and james buchanan here's
the thing i think this is interesting
but if you try to tell someone who's
like some kind of trumpist or right
winger about it they'd go the historians
are just left-wing shills and they'll
just ignore it you know
okay
that was my question but thank you oh no
problem yeah i mean i i hate to be like
kind of cynical but if they don't like
what it says they'll just say it's not
worth listening to you know
yep all right okay well he left i guess
maybe my answer was not uh not not
suitable but that's okay
let's go next to bobby from jersey bobby
welcome to the show
bobby from jersey welcome you're on the
air
hello david could you hear me yes now i
can
alright tremendous so what do you think
about gun debates it makes it so messy
of a topic to debate
what makes it messy well i think that
it's it's really a cultural issue
there are lots of people in the united
states
who are either
so enmeshed in gun culture
and i will also say that there's people
who are just viscerally opposed
to guns for cultural reasons
that it's very difficult to get past it
and to think about it like we would any
other
kind of empirical
circumstance and say okay well
what is the likelihood of a defensive
use of guns and are we really curtailing
the second amendment if we have some
restrictions and you know all these
different things now i know where i come
down on it i don't really have i mean
listen i'm disgusted by what we might
call
uh man how do i say it like
uh kind of like rural
rural right-wing gun culture i find it
completely disgusting and i want nothing
to do with with the folks who are part
of that but at the same time it's not
just for me about the guns i have lots
of friends who are liberal gun owners
and they're responsible and they want
licensing and insurance and they're safe
with their guns and all these different
things it's like hey we have a second
amendment you're not doing anything
wrong you're not kind of like a
fetishist where you're fetishizing guns
and whatever all these different things
so i think because people are so
ideologically connected to the issue it
prevents us from really speaking
substantively and i think if we spoke
substantively we would we would come
down on we need way more regulations on
guns
yes i completely agree and i feel it's a
safe that it just
it's pretty difficult to beat emotion
rather than like over empirical evidence
well that's going back to the
conversation earlier about abortion
imagine that we got an answer about when
life begins or when a fetus is a person
that was like scientifically definitive
first no one you would never have actual
everybody agreeing with it and even if
we did it wouldn't change everyone's
mind about abortion anyway so it's one
of these things where the vast majority
of the debate even if you resolve it
won't actually resolve the broader issue
yes yeah i feel like too many people
have such a binaries um a binary view on
like a lot of it a lot of issues and i
haven't
that's something that really annoys me
thank you david all right my pleasure
thank you so much for the call we're
getting some solid calls today guys i
have to say let's hope nobody nobody
ruins it now let's go to roman from
pittsburgh roman welcome
hey david how are you good good i have
to ask ro are you ukrainian or russian
by chance
um you know it's funny i moved to
cleveland and uh there's a lot of
eastern europeans around this part um
i'm italian wow there's a sandwich yeah
you know what's so funny about i've
never you would
there's lots of people who are not
familiar with the name roman
and when you tell them my name is roman
they go that must be because you're
italian and i've never met anyone with
that name who's actually italian they're
always russian or ukrainian but you
actually are italian and your name is
roman
yeah ironically it's uh it was my
parents favorite chapter in the bible
but i just there's a there's a sandwich
shop around here that makes a roman
burger so i joke that you know they just
were hungry when they were pricked my
mom was pregnant so fair enough all
right well what's on your mind today
um
i just wanted to comment i'm an
ultrasound tech or a sonographer
depending on how fancy you want to be
okay and um
you know i have a lot of history
scanning
early pregnancies so um seeing all these
bills pass it's very frustrating to see
these people who obviously have no
medical background trying to you know
make any assessment on you know roe v
wade or anything like that it's it's
very frustrating um most of the people i
i do ultrasounds with have no idea that
they're pregnant so um yeah and i think
there's i think this is interesting
there's two there's two sides to this
right one side of it is you often will
have a panel of like eight
seventy-year-old
men
saying we decide what's legal and
abortion and all this you know obg kob
care and all this different stuff that
makes absolutely no sense also
i think
sometimes when we take this too far we
get into the stuff where like during the
iraq war you had a lot of right wingers
going if you haven't been in the
military
you can't have an opinion about this war
and it's like no you can actually
actually you can so i think we want to
balance both sides of the this but your
point is very well taken
yeah um it's uh it's just one of those
things where um
the
uh medicine is like you know really
messy and like i think uh like even joe
rogan when he talks about it he's like
oh i'm pro-life uh or sorry pro-choice
but he's like it kind of gets really
messy when you talk about like late-term
abortions and i think that people really
get mired in those details and like 80
percent of abortions occur like less
before 12 weeks yeah um like a quarter
of pregnancies and before people even
realize that they're pregnant so
i feel like there's a lot of
misunderstandings of when abortions
happen and like why they happen um like
like just look i mean i'm not gonna tell
people to look up
some of these complex medical things but
like hydrocephalus like some like it's
not a viable thing like i don't think
that it makes sense to make someone
carry a baby that doesn't have a brain
to full term but i mean what are you
gonna do one of the other things that's
often mentioned in this discussion is
the right wingers will say
you know you it's crazy that you can
walk in at eight and a half months
pregnant and say abort and when you
actually talk to ob gyns they almost
universally say number one never happens
once you're eight and a half if if
you're if you're given a due date at 40
weeks and it's two weeks before that and
you walk in and you go i'd like to abort
first of all ob gyn say it never happens
number two they almost exclusively say i
also wouldn't do it at that point you go
wait a second yeah there's no medical
condition threatening your life no well
so why why would we do that let's talk
about adoption let's
obgyn say that's an imaginary situation
yeah i mean even at like 24 weeks you
can at least like
you know stabilize a pregnancy but like
before that i mean like it's it's not
even a conversation um hey real quick
i'm curious because you so you're in a
situation where you're doing the
ultrasounds for women who they may not
even know they're pregnant so why are
they getting an ultrasound if they don't
do what's the circumstance of them
getting an ultrasound
yeah so i mean we do a lot of different
ultrasounds i'm a gem what they call a
general ultrasound tech there are like
other ultrasound techs who uh specialize
in only doing ob
personally like the late term stuff is
it gets
i feel bad a lot of times for those
those people who only work in mfm
because a lot of times they are scanning
women who either have you know they're
at risk for some reason because that you
know they're most likely to come back
for like follow-up stance scans so
that's
maternal diabetes slash obesity
um
drug use
um twins makes you automatically at risk
some sort of um prior history of of
complication sure um for me it's um they
come in through the er and then they
have some sort of indication either pain
bleeding
um
they they came in with a positive
pregnancy test and
they had some sort of uh prior
ultrasound and uh some you know
sometimes they come in to like get a
follow-up i don't recommend that coming
in through the er
especially if you're coming in from a
different hospital system we won't have
that history sure um and you know it's
very rare that this happens but just you
know want to put this out there do not
come to try to get pictures if you're
coming in through the er
um we
we can't let you take pictures of the
screen it's like a legal issue and like
we don't have a printer because we're
not
designed to do these now because you're
a tech you're not delivering the news oh
hey you're pregnant right you're doing
the scanning and then a doctor says hey
this shows that you're pregnant
yeah
um we we write um
like a short little uh
a set like they call it like a tech
assessment yep and then um the
radiologist can either agree or disagree
with our assessment um
i yeah i keep my mouth shut and
personally i kind of like that um the
liability is not something i want um and
like i only needed you know two two
years of schooling the 10 years and a
hundred thousand dollars worth of that
just does not seem worth it you know i
gotcha i gotcha all right well listen i
appreciate you uh sharing about this
super interesting
can i ask you a really quick question
yeah go ahead
um do you think it's good for democrats
if ron desantis runs um too early to say
depends who he's running against i know
i know the point of the question which
is like
is he any is he a better or more
difficult candidate to defeat i just
think we don't know until we know who
the democratic nominee is
yeah i thought maybe if he ran against
trump that it might cause like almost a
slip split ticket like a ball oh in the
primary that's another question yeah
it's just too early to say
all right thank you very much all right
thank you so much appreciate the call
very very interesting i have to tell you
let's go next to lahav from greensboro
lahav welcome
hello can you hear me yes i can
okay um i'd like to ask about um the
system of government that we have in the
united states because
in my opinion oh you know like
multi-party parliamentary systems like
in germany or denmark
yes and other countries well i think
that's a pr preferable system because
mostly because of the multi-party aspect
i mean i have issues with the two-party
duopoly i'm curious just
what do you think of the idea of a
multi-party parliamentary system could
it work here
well whether it could work i mean i
think the answer is it depends how hard
we want to try i think it of course it
could work
i tend to like the multi-party
parliamentary system you often hear as a
stated downside of such a system that it
makes it too easy for extremists to get
representation so imagine that
uh you know five percent of the vote
goes to
the kkk party and that means that they
would get 21 or some number of seats in
the house of representatives or
something like that but i think there's
safeguards against that and i don't
think it's as big a risk maybe as as
some people believe it to me i also see
it as a way of you know we talk all the
time
how can we break the duopoly
and often we say well you got to get rid
of the electoral college and then you
got to do ranked choice voting and fix
campaign finance you know all these
different things
a multi-party parliamentary system at
least at the house of representatives
level might be a shortcut to breaking
the two-party duopoly so i'm very
positive for a number of reasons on it i
don't i'm not as knowledgeable about it
as someone who maybe lives in such a
system so there may be downsides i'm not
considering
well one downside
like israel is the biggest downside i
can think of because what they have is
each country has a cut off
for how for what percentage of the vote
you have to get to receive seats in
israel it is way too low you get like 20
parties in government in an endless
cycle of elections it's a complete mess
right other countries like germany have
a higher cut off now another issue i
actually support abolishing the senate
like
it's not democratic in its current form
i don't even see a better form of it and
if there was a parliamentary system i
don't see the point of a senate
oh i have ranted and raved about the
undemocratic nature of the senate
i forget the exact numbers but i think
it's something like the senators
representing 17 of the u.s population
can form a majority because of how
undemocratic it is
and um i i like you
when i think about how you fix the
senate you're basically making it the
house so do you yeah it's
the senate is a mess i'm with you
and final question this one is slightly
unrelated but i always get annoyed with
the media when they pretend
that both sides are equal and this is
just another partisan fight
and it's really not so how do you get
that sort of i'll call it the both sides
culture
out of the media particularly corporate
media you just have to repeat over and
over again
this is not a both sides thing so when
when corporate media has one person that
understands and accepts the science of
climate change and another person who
denies it and then you go well
both sides you guys kind of debate and
see who convinces who
one side is not based in reality and so
that's just a matter of i think if if
you if one is a guest in such a
situation you have to repeat that
there's a false neutrality that being
created here that's deceptive but you've
just got to keep repeating it over and
over again there's no other way
well from their perspective if
someone a climate denier is going to go
on to cnn and then the host will
announce that they're a liar they're
probably not going to actually go on so
it might be a discreet way to stop these
people from actually showing up on cable
news yeah i can't think of what it is
but maybe you're right maybe there is a
way
okay thank you for taking my call my
pleasure there is lahav from greensboro
and that is going to do it for calls
today we will take calls again
and i look forward to speaking to many
more of you next time
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
well i have a bag of mail to review with
you it's not a literal bag it's a
proverbial bag but it's a bag
nonetheless you can email info
davidpakman.com if you would like to get
a message through to us it may be
featured on an upcoming episode it may
not uh i'm going to start with um this
is this has to be a presented without
comment because it's so wacky but this
is the sort of thing that i get every
day and one of the things that i wonder
about is
what must be going on
in this person's life to think to write
such a message to someone they don't
know
um hey you racist liberal lunatics peter
puffer communist socialist socialism
culture f that's the f word
i hope you boy biden f's you you life
and all around you up
cuz if you retards not a word i use it's
just verbatim
cause if you retards believe that woman
testimony in that s show here what
somebody told somebody told somebody i
overheard that
you all bunch of butt buddy do each
other off air
so would you say this is truth
i would not say this is truth i would
not say that this message contains
the profile image has
a nascar vehicle
for this person who wrote in
all right folks let's continue it's
crazy out there a dwayne wrote in and
says i can't believe
you still defend this gene therapy
so dave
you're getting the fifth or the sixth i
assume they mean vaccines i don't know
dwayne says anyway this is old news but
i wanted your opinion on a list of
things trump did just a few things to
show he actually took them on the elite
obama hillary pelosi blah blah
the cutting taxes and regulations for
small business i couldn't tell exactly
what taxes but did he cut him
the person seems very confident in their
confusion
some people said they benefited more
money in their pockets never mind the
debt 25 trillion to china funding the
war in afghan and iraq okay never mind
that
did you get more money did he lower
taxes
my grammar is not the best i have common
sense over you high intellects with
degrees you can't get that from college
and i use short form like you and
couldn't okay i'm not putting quotation
marks like you freaks
i once met someone who used quotation
marks they were a freak
that's true
sec cut funding from who not on the
agenda
if people think he's with them a
globalist whatever globalists don't
agree with some of things he did so
first is cut taxes
second is cut money from who third cut
funding from nato not on the agenda
u.s was paying the most not part of eu
not on the ag so that's four so now five
nafta scrapped it yes he agreed to
another crappy deal but not on the ag6
obamacare which is scam
but i had a better one so we'll say five
for now eu cut funding can't remember
details but was getting out if had one
again that's six
there was one more can't remember can
you comment on those six
i can destroy the
sc failed vaccine and the fake pandemic
covet is real the word pandemic is fake
that's another topic
don't comment on my grammar
instead of a comma i can double tap the
space bar and it's a period
i'm on my phone
wow folks i can't do it i think i might
have to quit these emails are driving me
into retirement
all right now for some more substantive
things santa wrote in hey david assuming
democrats don't fight away find a way to
codify roe v wade into law anytime in
the near future do you think states
where abortion is legal
will have an entire industry of abortion
clinics start to develop along their
borders with states where it's illegal
if so what other things do you foresee
happening yeah this is interesting
because it reminds me when i grew up in
massachusetts it was known fireworks
were really i don't know if they're
still illegal in massachusetts fireworks
were illegal in massachusetts but legal
in new hampshire so there would be
fireworks stores
right on the border of new hampshire and
massachusetts and people would drive
there it almost seems certain
that we will see something similar with
abortion how would we not
how would we not and the question that
remains is whether
states that ban abortion
will try to prosecute those who leave
the state and legally get an abortion
elsewhere i don't think there's really a
legal basis for that
i've spoken to lawyers and they've not
ex they've not articulated to me how
would you do that if you go to a state
where an abortion is legal
it's sort of like if you go to
i don't know if you go to amsterdam
and consume cannabis where it's legal
and then come back to the u.s
to a state where it's illegal could the
state prosecute you for what you did in
amsterdam doesn't seem like it
so that's a question but uh i think you
will indeed see
such a such an industry develop and it's
a horrible thing to think about
mark wrote in about hearsay and asked hi
david is cassidy hutchinson's testimony
hearsay please share your thoughts if
you have a minute it seems part of it
could be and part of it not thanks for
all you do and congratulations on your
baby so there's two answers to this
question
is so hearsay is a legal term relevant
in courts of law
so the first question is why are we even
talking about hearsay in a congressional
hearing hearsay is allowed in
congressional hearings so that's not an
issue
second part
there are people who when they say is it
hearsay
you can tell believe that if it's
hearsay it can't be believed
sometimes hearsay is true
and so
whether or not it's hearsay is a
different question from whether or not
cassidy hutchinson's testimony was
accurate
and then third even in courts of law
there are dozens of hearsay exemptions
or exceptions wherein hearsay is allowed
so
yes cassidy because some of cassidy
hutchinson's testimony
if presented in a court of law would be
hearsay that has no bearing on its truth
and it has no bearing on whether it is
acceptable in a congressional uh hearing
matt rodin
a comment on tucker's june 28 show
hi sir heard your show on john eastman
on tucker's show tucker said they're
treating eastman like a drug kingpin or
a rapist shouldn't he have said a drunk
drug kingpin or a woman who just had an
illegal abortion i believe the
punishment is far worse
that than the actual rapist just a
thought yeah so i think the point being
made here by matt
is
there are many who want to criminalize
abortion usually they stop short of
saying uh criminalize the woman's action
they will often say criminalize the
doctor
uh etc
but point well taken they are sort of
relegating women
seeking medical services
to
uh criminals and that's crazy
a few other aggressive ones
whose payroll are you on a whole no
matter what they're paying you you're
going against your country you piece of
s
f u
uh i'm not on anyone's payroll other
than yours
it's the people in the audience who
support the work that we do
so
i guess i'm on my own payroll in that i
own my own business
and i'm on the payroll of the audience
because the audience funds the show
beyond that you know whenever people
talk about
soros or
whoever else is paying me prove it prove
someone other than the audience
uh and our few advertisers are paying me
please
uh do you guys get triggered much
because it seems like you do
do you care on all the riots the
democrats did for the last six years
i'll wait for your response
well
i have unequivocally
denounced violence
and uh
it has been something i've said
regardless of who's doing it or the
political orientation of those doing it
we know that in the united states the
overwhelming majority of politically
motivated violence is perpetrated by the
right
not by the left
democrats did riots for six years you're
gonna have to remind me about that when
there has been violence or criminality
at whatever protest black lives matter
entrepha anything
i say i'm against that and if crimes
have been committed then people should
be dealt with in the criminal justice
system
and we saw nothing from them
like what we saw on january 6th so i
hope that you weren't waiting too long
and i hope that i answered your question
last one
you have a chance to see two thousand
mules but i think you're while you are
afraid to watch
and read the laptop from hell
your president and his nasty son
all over it
i have now talked about 2 000 mules
three times i think that is more than
sufficient for
how rigorous it is
three times i've spoken about 2 000
mules
i have spoken about the hunter biden
laptop now probably closer to six or
seven times
i've basically said everything i think
should be said about it
based on what we know so far
if you think there's something specific
that should be said that i haven't said
let me know maybe even call into the
show we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
sign up at joinpacman.com
that's p-a-k-m-a-n
dot com to get instant access to the
bonus show you also get the daily
podcast in either audio or video form
whichever form you prefer when you're a
member
that podcast full show is made available
to you five or six hours earlier than we
publish it to everybody else
and when we do our town hall events you
get priority access when you are a
member
join pacman.com coupon code big voting22
we will see you on the bonus show and
then we will see you next week
you